jenny were you shaking when you it
looked like you were shaking
and licked literally physically shaking
i was literal i was waiting for when
that rooster had came off
and then i saw donnie i was waiting for
one of those james bond like
donny mask to come off and to be another
celebrity because there's no way
and i lost my footing my knees started
to buckle and i fell on the ground and i
was shaking for about an hour
[Applause]
and then all i can envision in my head
was that moment in game of thrones when
she's doing her atonement walk and it's
just
shame the shame bell right because i'm
like i know
all of twitter is gonna hit me up going
what's wrong with you
jenny you are really close to your
husband
how don't you know that voice every time
you hear it
i i mean i should but there was there's
a lot of
things that you have to put in place
before you judge me
one is he tricked me he would actually
facetime me
from massing her set dressed as danny
reagan
and say i'm on set and blue and then he
would have me talk he'd like let me say
hi
robin or nicole or ken and they're like
how's new york and he's like it's
freezing and then he posts on instagram
a picture of him in new york so my brain
is not thinking done
yeah and also you know i couldn't really
move the way i like to move
typically you know on stage right i i
like i did a little butt wiggle and got
my hips going and stuff but i
i had a a little slight tear in my calf
muscle from wearing those talons on my
feet
and trying to dance and also had a big
tail that weighed about 10 pounds in a
rooster head that weighed about another
25 pounds so i don't think
my moves were as precise and
quite the moves that she would recognize
but thousands of his fans knew
exactly who it was the moment he opened
up his mouth
okay so here's what i want to know that
you're going to these great lengths to
fool
your wife at what point like what do you
do at night after you finish shooting
where do you go well typical
so what i have to do is really focus on
her schedule
so one of the the lucky things for me is
east coast and west coast are three
hours apart so if i'm on
in new york shooting blue bloods in a
bubble and she's in la
shooting mass singer in a bubble our
hours don't always align
and when she's on the panel she can only
use her phone for very
short amounts of time because they don't
want the panelists you know googling
right holding up the zam or trying to
recognize the voice right so
they have to they have certain
restrictions that
allowed me to have windows of time that
generally speaking
we talk every five minutes when we're
not together like we're constantly like
we don't
like look at our friend and go what'd
you think about the game last night i'll
call her
like what you think about this you know
we talk 24 hours a day so
when she was working and when i'm
working it gave me enough
windows of time to sort of sneak around
and do what i had to do
jenny there were clues throughout the
season did any of them
any of them kind of turn on or spark
anything in your head
that it could possibly be your husband
all right let me give you a little
secret they they inserted some of those
clues in post
so we didn't necessarily see some of
those clues
there were some obvious ones that i went
but there were definitely some inserted
later possibly on purpose so i didn't
really sniff it out too much
yeah really okay cause you i mean i
literally i know how close you two are
you two are like
the couple like i would think if you saw
a man walking down the street from
behind you'd say
that's my husband right there he's like
what do you mean no that's my husband
the guy in the crowd he left the bracket
yeah it's my butt from anywhere
she was recognizing my butt from
anywhere but there was a giant tail in
the way
how much fun donnie was it to be a part
of jenny's world in this
way you know knowing that you're pulling
this off and
like each and every time you go on
looking out at her what was that like
you know it's like i'm a disney
character at disneyland
in the goofy costume right and i'm
looking through a screen at them
and wondering like are they feeling this
are they vibing with me
are they did they because they all hated
pluto dude
before i performed so i was like are
they gonna even they might like throw me
off the stage
that was the fun part i will say because
he was a disrupter you know
so every time like changed the clues and
we were literally verbally abusing them
all season like we
hate you and i'm thinking back to
everything that i said i'm like i
can't stand that character who is that
person
just total shade and then his head comes
off and i lose my head
yeah i had to literally say to myself
just
do the best performance you can do if
they stop you and throw you off the
stage because they hate cluedo do then
there's nothing you can do about it just
roll with it and see what happens i just
you know i i just had to focus on what i
had to do and you were
amazing thank you all right look we are
gearing up for a big finale week here
um how was it for the unmasking this
week jenny
oh so hard and i know every season we're
like it's the most difficult finale ever
but it
truly is the three that are left
chameleon
piglet black swan are professionals
like these are some iconic pros and i'm
so grateful they started to include a
live audience to vote so the press is
not on all of us
you can't get mad at just the judges
everybody america's voting also
it is going to be a tough one because
they all slay
yeah who do you think walks away with
golden air
uh well you know i always like to toot
my own horn
but i obviously did not do that great of
a job this year
but who knows you'll have to tune in to
see
ken and i are tied right now yeah yeah
okay
all right i like that donnie are you any
more surprises for jenny i mean anything
else you got up your sleeve
um
better not yeah you know um and and
here's the other thing
did you know who everybody was did you
know
yeah did you know who anybody else was i
would be the worst judge
on mass singer i would never guess
anyone
i don't know who anyone is i'm literally
like
you know watching it and i don't know
who anyone is and
i've watched it on tv and jenny's like
that's donnie that's my husband and i'm
like is it me
it doesn't does it sound like me like i
don't know
you know i'm good with faces that's why
i play danny reagan i'm not good with
voices that's why she's the golden ear
and i'm not
leanne rimes is coming back for the
finale right that'll be big
is yes she was one of my favorite along
with t-pain
throughout the season and man she's got
a voice on her and she makes a pretty
good judge i will say
yeah yeah what is the difference for her
from being having the costume on to now
and sitting
on the other side relief that's what
i'll say
relief and you know she has like donnie
empathy towards these you know artists
who get up there
each week and perform it's not easy
yeah it's not easy it's not he's like
legendary performers have
struggled under the mass yeah you know
and yeah and
so you then you take someone who doesn't
even sing
who's getting under there and trying to
actually pull it off it's
it's got to be very stressful
you